pop
[Musique]
le 11 octobre 14 121 le greffier de
l'échevinage d'arras note sur ses
registres
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
au xvème siècle les premiers groupe de
tziganes sont signalés en europe
occidentale
leur mode de vie leurs langues leurs
coutumes diffère de celle en tête
il suscite la curiosité mais aussi la
peur forgeron musicien batteur de 20 il
fascine il est abusif
[Musique]
il se donne souvent des titres princiers
comme dupes ou compte des égyptiens de
nombreuses familles seigneuriales de
france et du cos les accueille et les
protègent en 780 gle louis xiv affirme
il a été impossible de chasse est
entièrement du royaume ces voleurs par
la protection qu'ils ont de tout temps
troublés et qu'il trouve journellement
auprès de gentilshommes et seigneur
justicier qu'il ordonne retraite dans
leur château et maison
[Musique]
l'histoire des tziganes et surtout
l'histoire d'une répression au xvième
siècle des ordonnances d'expulsion sont
prononcées contre eux au xviiie siècle
les pays-bas organise des battues à
tzigane
cinquante ans plus tard il n'en reste
plus un seul en 1725 en prusse tout
homme ou femme tziganes et pendu quand
on ne les tue pas on les condamne au
fouet et aux galères en france sous le
consulat on interne les tsiganes et l'on
songe à les déportés en louisiane
au xxème siècle en janvier 38 les
autorités allemandes déclare pour des
raisons de santé publique et en
particulier parce que les tsiganes ont
une hérédité notoirement chargé que ce
sont des criminels invétéré qui
constituent des parasites au sein de
notre peuple et qu'il ne serait qu'
produire des dommages immenses mettant
en grand péril la pureté du sang en
septembre 39 heydrich décide leur
extermination à auschwitz dans la nuit
du 31 juillet au 1er août
laissé sans tzigane survivants sont
massacrés 500000 tsiganes ont péri sous
le régime nazi
[Musique]
ils ont survécu des moyens différents de
toutes les révolutions de l'ère
industrielle et de l'âge atomique
leur histoire n'est pas la no il faut
oublier pour les comprendre nous repère
chronologique et jusqu'à notre notion du
passé le tsigane vie son histoire au
moment où il la raconte le peuple
tzigane se répartit en trois groupes les
hommes les manouches l'egypte en tout
cas les
[Musique]
de fania
tu es
mende
non
ah oui
gitans vient du mot egypte anneaux
référence à une origine égyptienne plus
ou moins légendaire le même s'appelle
calais qui vient du mot sens leasing
calais signifiant homme noir de la
plaine
les gitans vivent dans les pays
méditerranéens et surtout en espagne
leur arrivée semble antérieure à
l'arrivée les autres tzigane en europe
occidentale on ne connaît rien de leur
migration leurs traditions et coutumes
ont fortement imprégné la culture
andalouse
[Musique]
tél
et
rhodia
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il
et
[Musique]
je rencontre mon moment l'hydrologue
oh
ap
[Musique]
le pèlerinage des saintes maries de la
mer rassemble chaque année près de 20000
tzigane
il date du 16e siècle
mais les tsiganes qui viennent que
depuis le siècle dernier
[Musique]
aujourd'hui les saintes maries sont
devenus surtout un lieu de réjouissances
et pour ces hommes que l'on chasse de
partout un moyen légal de se retrouver
en grand nombre
[Musique]
c'est comme ça qu'ils croient au ciel de
marie de la mer qui croient en un seul
homme mais les saintes maries de la mer
s'était fait de pire s'il n'est pas prêt
zidane zidane et la piété des tziganes
et éclectique
qu'ils soient catholiques protestants
orthodoxes il interprète les cultes et
les rites à leur façon pour les
catholiques sainte sara l'égyptienne et
la médiatrice du peuple tzigane
[Musique]
comme il l'est pour camille radou parce
que je m'étais demandé rien non cet
animal de remixes qui se nomme la
tendance craignons que le génome obama
allait alors vous avez mal aux reins et
à l'abdomen
le miracle qui t'a fait acquis ce qui te
demander à dieu était nommé dont s'est
pas laissé échapper le miracle ce dieu
que tu as fait le mur à gauche ah bon
c'est pas pareil
qu'est ce que tu crois plus dieu où vous
serez là dedans je vais l'aider
62ème petit oiseau de malheur mais si
vous déménagez
[Musique]
ma
où
non
[Musique]
ils ont longtemps circulé en allemagne
et l'on retrouve dans leur langue du
traces germanique violoniste leurs
improvisations ont fortement marqué les
folklores cela est malien manouche vient
d'un mot sanskrit qui veut dire l'homme
vrai
[Musique]
allez pas vous chasser
je me dis il n'y avait pas eu de mots
rien du tout là bas c'était malheureux
oui
[Musique]
non
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on
m
[Musique]
on a passé de la mise et pendant la
guerre on a laissé notre voiture on a
laissé les autres on le sait tous on n'a
pas pu a plus une à souffrir là on reste
des trois jours sans manger
à cette époque comme il y en avait
beaucoup il était dans les cas beaucoup
aussi les manches vous laetitia france
après
avec les maquis réjouit jouer pour le
monde touchant les membres qui sait bien
comment kessel et j'aime la musique ils
aiment leur vie ils aiment la liberté
voilà il a été annoté garante pour
pouvoir vivre alors là bas j'étais un
peu niais mais il y avait beaucoup de
bagarres des
les matières que les allemands sa passe
est mal la nuit on allait la guerre sur
les chemins de fer tout ça après on a
repris notre vie comme avant après après
qu'ils ont parlé
les allemands de la france on a acheté
des chevaux la jetée
o la partie en voyage on appris la vie
comme les manouches art un complément
nous occupe
[Musique]
on
m
[Musique]
me
on
[Musique]
m
complet
[Musique]
tu veux que je fais là l'idée la même
algérie dame de la main à la main gauche
les voyageurs dommage les roms se
considère comme l'aristocratie des
tsiganes si on les rencontre aujourd'hui
dans le monde entier
ils ont été les derniers à atteindre
l'europe occidentale et pour cette
raison sont restés très traditionaliste
chaque sous-groupe est réputé pour un
métier particulier leurs femmes ont une
spécialité ancestrale lire les lignes de
la main
qu'est ce que vous pensez vous avez
dépensé votre fortune c'est justement ce
qui vous manque c'est la santé c'est la
joie moi je vais te dit quelque chose
que tu seras encore beaucoup plus
tranquille madame madame on s'est révélé
très contente que vous allez voir passer
votre main vous les vents du bonheur ma
fille allait donner mon ventre mais
j'ose dire quelque chose d'intéressant
et vous inquiétez pas c'est la main
gauche cela met du coeur toujours qui
travaillent vous allez vivre très
longtemps mademoiselle jusqu'à l'âge de
85 ans dans l'avenir de ce moment
seulement que de deux petits enfants une
petite fille et un petit garçon
vous aimez la paix mademoiselle vous
aimez la tranquillité mais vous demandez
pas la solitude vous allaitez d'un grand
voyage vous êtes amoureuse quelquefois
mais quelques fois vous avez des goûts
et spécial vous avez des vhu ordinaire
vous et vous avez apprécié des personnes
mais quelquefois vous réfléchissez que
c'est pas de votre goût et le plaisir la
vérité répondez moi c'est vrai on
pourrait vous de la famille vous êtes
gâtés vous êtes une fille travailleuse
mais vous êtes gâtés mais vous faites
beaucoup à votre tête vous faites
beaucoup à vos idées c'est vrai
voilà
alors pour vous faites attention
maintenant vous êtes préoccupé pour une
personne mais vous n'êtes pas plus sûr
de lui vous êtes entre les deux mon
coeur balance
comme nous allons vous pensez vous
n'avez pas de chance mademoiselle mais
vous avez de la chance ne vous savez pas
la prendre pour que vous êtes un
nerveuse et vous êtes une fille très
capricieuse caprice que vous avez vous
lu qu'après sur l'art est toujours pensé
dans votre coeur vous est donné aux
saintes maries de la mer c'est pour voir
la suite des gitans ou que vous avez
quelque chose encore dans les gitans que
vous tenez c'est la vérité nue
l'entendement et votre cure il était
honnête mademoiselle vous avez la tête
haute dans la ville mais il ya beaucoup
de personnes qui vous parle mal devant
votre visage c'est bien mademoiselle
mais derrière vous c'est très mauvais
vous avez déjà donné confiance à une
personne n'avait confiance que vous avez
donnée avec confiance vous avez perdu
mais maintenant je vais vous dire un
petit secret et je vais vous dire les
initiales de la personne qui pense à
vous oui oui mais sérieusement je vous
parle moi c'est pas penser que je vous
parle comme ça pour vous faire vous
écoutez moi bien
il ya la liturgie à la lettonie qui
pense à vous c'est le nom de famille
[Musique]
oui alors vous allez voir un grand
cadeau mais moi en tant qu'etat mais
vous allez faire un grand mariage mais
un mariage d'amour vous n'allez pas sur
un mariage d'argent et vous serez très
fidèle mais moi je vais te donner la
petite médaille 17 maries de la mer
ça va te porter bonheur s'arrêter pour
tes chances dans les z'amours toi jamais
des ennuis dans l'avenir à l'envoyer
mademoiselle pour la ligne de la main
moi je fais la ligne de la main des
personnes très riches avait personne
très peur tout le monde y donne pour moi
qu'elle sera 20 francs différent des
bancaires qu'est ce que vous avez comme
volonté pour donner d'où viennent les
tsiganes d'egypte comme ils le
prétendent eux mêmes ou de chaldée des
recherches linguistiques ont déterminé
au moins pour leur langue
une origine indienne il est difficile de
préciser de quelle région de l'inde et
de quel groupe ethnique ils proviennent
mais tous qu'ils soient roms manouches
ou calais se reconnaissent comme sommes
supérieures face au nom de six gagnent
qu'ils appellent gadjo gadjo paysans
sédentaires
si mu à ses enfants et son gendre
pasteur pentecôtiste appartiennent au
groupe des roms
caldera ch c'est à dire les roms
chaudronnier
je ne pense pas coutume qu'on accomplit
en israël je dis beaucoup la bible et
j'ai vu que dans la bible il ya à peu
près des coutumes que nous avons
également compte dans l'ancien testament
1 j'ai passé plus tôt qui ont intégré et
peut-être qu'on a passés par les haines
la russie est comme ça que les roms ils
se sont ils sont peu partout dans le
monde aujourd'hui mais ça c'est qu'on
n'a pas cette culture ne pas savoir du
pollen ne pas savoir d'où on vient parce
qu'on n'a pas connu partout dans le
monde et oui et comment votre côté mais
nous y emmener partout on est dans le
monde à gilles parent et partout ils
d'accord suis d'accord avec vous mais
seulement comment on ne peut pas savoir
notre source
d'une part nous ne sais pas et je ne
crois pas qu'on trouvera exactement d'où
nous venons
je savait ni lire ni écrire
alors comme je voyais que les gens ils
prennent de la bible elysées et j'étais
émerveillé des belles paroles qui est
écrite
j'ai acheté des livres j'ai appris comme
les gosses à baisser mais alors c'était
difficile pour pouvoir voir d'ensemble
l'ailé j'ai demandé les d'adieu et
finalement comme ça par moi même j'ai
appris à lire et ses traders
qu'est ce que tu as fait qu'est ce que
le seigneur il a aidé à faire mais
seulement nos jeunes y vont souvent à
l'école maintenant qu'ils sont obligés
d'aller à l'école dégagé et ça s'appelle
l'école française j'aurais aimé d'avoir
une école on y met à leur apprendre à
lire et à écrire en français et nous
culture réunion à manono nos cultures
avec les jeunes d'aujourd'hui que je le
vois il change énormément n'entrera plus
garder notre tradition et je voudrais
pas que ça ça se perdent et se venge
demo à tes enfants à mes enfants de
paille à l'école parce qu'on pourra plus
garder la parole d'al et du parole en
parle parce que moi tu vois bien je suis
un peu haché ni lire ni écrire mais ça
m'a pas empêché d'être juif et que je
ressens les mêmes choses que les gens
qui s'est irritée
[Musique]
vous avez des papiers d'identité les
papiers du véhicule
monsieur l'eau si vous êtes combien de
familles deux familles
merci + a été contrôlé déjà oui
messieurs oui quand je sais pas je me
rappelle plus inquiétant maximum
les papiers ça veut dire rapidement très
vite
non mais non mais jusqu'où vous allez
nous chasser comme ça vous avez les
papiers du véhicule s'il vous plaît les
papiers du véhicule
vous n'avez que cette opel et puis 403
oui record opel 39 n à 77,12 les alors
je peux rester vous attendez je me donne
les résultats du contrôle
[Musique]
les rapports avec la maréchaussée ont
toujours été difficiles
les noms que les tsiganes déclara
l'administration sont emprunté au
vocabulaire en usage chez les gadjé mais
selon d'emprunt sert à dissimuler leur
vrai nom il s'agit selon à l'auteur
tzigane d'une forme d'orgueil de caste
qui se refuse à livrer à tout le monde
un bien aussi intime que son nom vous
venez chercher vos papiers
approché le contrôle est terminée le
pouvoir continuer votre route voilà vos
cartes d'identité et les papiers du
véhicule
le maire vous avez donné un délai pour
quitter le coin non non je crois que
nous avons des minutes oui vous partez
maintenant pour l'état civil la police
pour sept ans l'aigle question des
papiers nous acceptons les lois du pays
où nous sommes mais au milieu de tout ça
il y à nos lois
nous sommes un peuple à part et nous
avons de l'autre et loi y'a pas croire
comme on l'a dit mais sans world droit
et on vit entre nous et on s'entend très
bien
[Musique]
à plat
la vie
[Musique]
le
m
[Musique]
si vous avez sa famille sont en route
vers florence où elle doit rencontrer le
maire monsieur mességué qui soigne avec
les plans elle pense également pouvoir
conclure un mariage dans la région pour
l'un de ses fils
bon
[Musique]
on
m
ans
[Musique]
on
jorion
[Musique]
j'étais mariée très jeune j'avais à peu
près 15 ans c'était jeunes qu'on a vu la
pâle à tout on est venu me chercher
parce que j'étais d'abord moi aussi
laissé ce qu'ils sont venus me chercher
habite à paris mais sont venus me
chercher du coup quel virage c'était la
famille qu'elle des lâches ma maman
systémique et brigitte à paris met donc
en tribu qui m'a demandé en mariage mais
avant qu'on essaie de tribunes des
mandats marie à ce plaisir entre le jour
de mon mariage
les gestes et les mangas mari je savais
même pas besoin me relate à lui n'est
pas là tout est veille
non ça me ferait rêver la mort me
cherchez pas ton se tromper en disant
oui oui après ton père et mon mieux pour
me voir et puis seulement 10 envoyé sa
maman ne sont pas frères l'aîné tunis
allait me demander à marie à chauray
mariage c'est une chose chez nous très
difficile comment je pourrais dire c'est
très secret le mariage c'est notre moyen
d'imc à des peines a rappelé m en
réalité je vais te dire chez nous quand
une fille ce mari n'a pas le droit de
lurs ses films nommés plus haut à qui ça
peut appeler mais elles n'ont cessé gré
et en vérité l'homme il la quitte pas
donc alors je viens de te dirai pas
vendre la condition enseignante mais
qu'ils allaient ce thème à mickey c'est
vrai qu'à part abou salah s'est juré en
français ça veut dire tu quitteras ton
mari un qui quittera la cuillère de ta
bouche senki mystère sienne mais
j'aimerais que les seigneurs et me donne
une romy envolée comme défi
parce que la gamine et le tradiction
qu'on a gardé l'arbre mais cela me
laisse de la mini jupe et ne nous
avaient pas le droit de vous habiller
votre demande et en étant jeune fille
vous pouvez encore vous habiller
autrement il faut à marier vous avez vu
le droit de les habiller de vêtements
longs et jamais la tête découverte parce
que c'est l'alliance des coutumes de
chine ou non pas l'alliance
on doit on à la liesse qui est couvert
la tête
donc on n'a plus le droit de faire
qu'est-ce qu'on fait parce que c'est
déjà sur une femme qui marie il n'a plus
droit de décoiffer de monlézun il n'a
pas le droit devant passer de 20 ans
il doit lui dire tourne toi que je
puisse passer
[Musique]
bonjour monsieur l'un présentant la
maison maximum passant pour les
réparations de tonnage des réparations
deux enseignes de cuisine biais là nous
demandons aux gens un échantillon pour
vous démontrer le travail que ces
voiliers parce que nous sommes des états
mère de ce dernier voyait faisant les
champions comme démonstration de travail
maintenant
possible
comprenez non mais c'est la france
vérité je vous fait voir la carte nous
faisons même l'outil à vous voyez pas ce
que te dévoile un merci beaucoup
et le voilà maintenant porter quelqu'un
que j'aurais besoin d'être fait oui je
vois et vous avez des chevrons peut-être
des chaudrons des personnes ont crié
oui je vois et puis faudrait oui ça nous
faisons un neuf et tout maintenant je
peux vous faire un prix si vous avez un
autre on discute on peut en faire un
prix oui oh écoutez je travaille depuis
voodoo présent correctement représentés
dans la farine et non non non mais je
peux vous en présenter la même les tests
vous voulez vous savez les fontaines et
elle est elle aussi je connais les prix
oui et vous il me faire l'inventaire des
griffes des casseroles depuis que j'ai
l'accusé l'aurait suivi les femmes tous
là pour 5000 trois mois je vous l'achète
non non non il est pas vendre vous savez
comment je vais le nettoyer moi je vais
mettre dans du lait il va se nettoyer
oui mais comment mais comme que j'aurais
fait moi et donc j'aurais été étonnés
vraiment parce que vous avez oui mais
parce que sa mère et le fils il voulait
me donner aux petits poneys
bah oui mais justement parce que vous
avez tomber sur l'occasion il faut dire
parce que vraiment parce que vraiment
c'est pour dire que vous connaissez des
levées c'est autre chose
les tsiganes et les roms en particulier
ont toujours été réputés pour leur
adresse à travailler le métal techniques
qu'ils doivent sans doute à leur origine
indienne le fer indiens était déjà
réputée dans le monde romain en turquie
en hongrie en pologne
ils furent souvent employée par les
souverains pour forger des ustensiles de
factures délicate ou tout simplement
pour fabriquer des armes
bové oui justement les réparant de l'ema
retombé en étant 9 vous faire voir un
échantillonnage enfin démonstrations de
travail
alors là vous me donnez nous faire voir
un échange star si depuis vous avez dire
si santa fe vous passez savez bien sûr
[Musique]
oui si ça sera à faire ça parce que vous
compreniez même quand vous faites la
cuisine honda et puis ça reste pas bien
droit sur le feu tout et tout et comme
c'est à l'intérieur ça sera oui pour
l'échantillon et puis comme ça oui mais
ça c'est un échantillon comprenant
journée il faut faire et gratuit comme
ça ou vers le trail pu apprendre en
discuter le prix
les vacances
peut-être envie de la refaire
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
là
oh
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oh
belga
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ces terminaux pistre et comprend le
charbo
nager mois
[Musique]
d'une climatologie que tu écoutes baby
je vais te raconter une histoire
j'écoute est vrai quand mes parents y
sont nous
mes grands parents qui sont venus de la
russie mais son parti vraiment vraiment
tu veux savoir la vérité
avant la révolution ils ont senti parce
que c'est dit s'ils gagnent ils le
sentent
parce qu'ils sont toujours touchés un
peu par les guerres et par les camps
alors quand ils sentent quelque chose
dans un pays vont dans un autre pays
parce que c'est des nomades et on était
avec les voitures
le chevaux des belletante qu'on campe et
en france on était très bien on les sait
quand et n'importe
on nous accueille avec une chose
magnifique à comment convertir
maintenant si je comprends ont été
accueillis ont vraiment mieux que
maintenant s'il ya de la place pour mais
aussi puisqu'il ne sommes pas qu'un
petit monde ne sommes pas deux trois ans
nous sommes une nation alors je ferai
pas dire que nous battons depuis
tellement demande mais nous sommes
faibles pour le voyage résumons le
voyage notre pays c'est ou connaît on
sait qu on pose les pieds à ce moment là
les jeunes tu sais comment je pourrais
dire il écoutez bien les lieux il ne
souffre ans nous l'avons passer le temps
mais moi dans mon enfance et j'ai
souffert mais c'est la plus grande joie
le plus grand bonheur que je peux me
rappeler se venger mandat grammaire j'ai
dit tout comme des saints est ce qu ont
eu une descendance
et pourquoi que l'on n'a pas des églises
ils m'ont dit quand on était
allah les juifs qui nous dv3 sûrs alors
je lui demander mais pourquoi qu'il nous
doit trois jours les juifs il dit quand
le seigneur a fait le monde s'attendait
à un symbole un an et je n'en sais rien
je te le dis comme la grammaire et mieux
leur apprendre et aider mes souvenirs
elle m'a dit nous et s'ils gagnent on a
donné un coup de main pour construire
leur muse et donc c'était pour faire là
notre église est venu le jour de sa
basse et les juifs
ils sont arrêtés ils n'ont pas pu
travailler ce jour là donc c'est pour ça
que g et hamadi que nous n'avez pas
d'église et conserver des l'église du
pays où qu'on se trouvait quand un
enfant né sait on allait en baptisé nous
sommes ensemble au bout d'une usure
fallu qu'ils soient baptisés pas plus
parce que chez nous c'est un pur la
femme n'a pas le droit de sortir pendant
six semaines et doit rester bien
camouflé personne doit la voir un enfant
dans le berserk ans qu'il est au coucher
du soleil
immédiatement on doit mettre un petit
morceau de fer pour le protéger vous
voulez danser et de tout est mauvais
esprit certains jeunes n'y croient pas
tout ça mais nous les siennes on croit
beaucoup des choses ici le pam acheter
des plats probable d'un
[Musique]
vous allez devenir un jour va pas trop
bien la jolie
[Musique]
je n'y vois un peu je veux montrer
quelque chose de beau mais ça vaut rien
devoir vous voyez pas c'est bien fini un
projet qui peut toucher un déballage en
plein jour j'ai viendra que je vous
faire un petit cadeau de toute façon
c'est toujours ça qu'est-ce qui fait
cegid au mauvais les gitans non et je
peux prouver l'origine ans et sa femme
ou et non c'est gentil dans l'emploi les
yeux vous les faits de papier tout de
suite et pourquoi moi vous demandez tout
de suite pourquoi pour qui vous me près
les employés de suite
vous l'attendez même jeu que j'ai
développé en privé qu'est ce que vous
avez peur pour ça que je vais pas vous
payer est appelée patron risque d'une
âpre où le oui je me servais vous êtes
un cas très fort ça pour servir oui ou
non
à bize et maintenant c'est le 13 vous
étiez pour servir vous allez choisir à
petit vous roulez mais pourquoi ne pas
prendre vous autres quoi on écoutait
autres membres vous hein
bonjour madame d'un rhume acheter
quelque chose j'ai déjà quelque chose à
montrer pourquoi maintenant dans une
pique
je voudrais quelque chose de très beau
regard nouveau petit service puis la
jolie voix un patron n'est pas ici n ya
pas de patrons alors partout que j'ai vu
il n'y a pas de patron et l'europe c'est
qui les emploient je sais que vous êtes
une bonne mois profite à chez moi
quelque chose à voulait pas que je vous
dise un petit peu la ligne l'année et je
redis ce vote rechange votre bonheur
donnez moi votre main gauche
bonjour madame n'est pas m'acheter des
jeux de fille tina pour mal à regarder
un petit peu c'est joli et voudrait pas
que je vous dise m qui fait votre chance
votre bonheur au revoir je n'avais pas
madame oui mais moi je vois des choses
dans votre vie où vous en avez
après la plus vous aurez de beauté en
madone montrer même qui fait votre main
gauche je vais vous dire deux mots très
intéressant mais il pas peur je vais pas
changer votre main gauche molle
vous avez une wii vous allez vivre
jusqu'à l'âge de 96 ans et demi mais
seulement je vois votre ligne de vie
coupée un petit peu où vous avez eu un
petit accident ou une grande malade mais
c'est fait il ya plus de dangers
produits hors écran vous voyez vous
madame vous avez beaucoup se faire dans
mon existence
essayez de la bouche vous rigolez mais
qu'est ce que vous avez dans le coeur
personne ne le comprend et a comme le
religieux je comprends votre peine et
votre douleur se comprend quand vous
dormez vous faites ça dans votre vie
vous vous tournez vous vous demandez
qu'est ce que vous allez divine irrmann
à n'ai pas peur vous avez ce cerveau
vous avez énormément souffert vous avez
versé beaucoup de larmes sur la lenga
meuse vous souffrez république dans
votre coeur madame est dans de beaux
draps
n'ayez pas peur vous avez perdu
quelqu'un de cher dans la famille la
personne que vous avez perdu vous avez
beaucoup régressé
et quand vous pensez vous encore vous
lui devez une critique rien parce qu'au
delà il vous protège vous ne comprenez
bien et non 12 ans 13 ans qu'elle est
celle de telma manquait jamais de votre
maison
les penne les soucis c'est une super
dans la maison tout en le maintenant ce
sera fini mal vous aurez une virose vous
aurez une vie content tu ne connais bien
maintenant reprendre pensez vous déposez
que jamais dire à personne parce que je
vois le voyez vous dans votre maison
votre mariage vous avez beaucoup du
bonheur beaucoup de chance en bretagne
mais a eu quelqu'un le jour de votre
mariage est quelqu'un qui était pas
beaucoup de temps à regarder sauve avec
des mots veilleux et vous avez eu
l'impression que ça vous a subi tout le
temps ce n'est pas permanent le soleil
brillera pour vous aussi vous avez été
très touché par le puits par les saisies
par les angoisses ils ne seraient plus
touchés
et moi qu'est ce que vous désirez voir
le mieux notre coeur que vous pouvez pas
arriver que vous voudrez arriver parle
moi que gouverneur n'est pas permis oui
parle à coeur ouvert
c'est vraiment joli pourquoi ma mère
savait ça fait rien on vous parlait pas
mais dans votre coeur je vois qu est ce
que vous pensez et vous allez le dire et
bientôt de votre douleur de vaupés
niveau social
dre vous êtes fatigué vous êtes moi je
suis surveillé
j'ai reçu en short et d'un accident et à
la chaux il reste comme ça c'est grave
pour mémoire des choses
si c'est en vous que vous êtes un peu
malade je pourrais vous dire quelque
chose pour pouvoir vous soulagé pour
guérir parce que nous les tsiganes ont
connu beaucoup des choses ont connu
beaucoup des plantes ont connu beaucoup
d'erreurs mais le malheureusement le
shop vous avez reçu c'est dans le coeur
et c'est grave ça semble y passa
qu'est-ce que vous avez reste je le sais
je les ai vus dans votre mais c'est
grave mais n'ayez pas peur
le bolliger vous donnera le courage pour
pouvoir supporter
je ferai le biais du trille or ne
pleurez pas
pas pleurer moi je les prends
bah
merci
et j'ai regardé la télévision gifi qui
est à paris j'ai dit voilà un homme qui
va mourir
je vais vous avez vous améliorez l'on
pourrait boire ça je pourrais guérir les
modules serre mais si je savais que
c'est vivable s'aguerrit lui certes si
je saurai que c'est probable c'est par
le biais guéri du caire
le choeur oui c'est vrai les fleurs de
me guérir les soeurs ne faut pas dix pas
trompé dans un tank et il faut le faire
chez ces mesures on doit bouillir 9
fétiche
voyez vous voilà les deux jets mainate
non mais je vais en prendre mais ce
n'est pas mon métier alors et vous
pouvez en maman florence grimal à dire
je n'y vois encore proposé de venir que
mes enfants ils pourraient travailler
voyez pas ce qui les aide dans une
mesure qui sont maintenant je pourrais
dire vous savez il n'ya pas de miracle
moi j'ai beaucoup d'expérience et le
secret de la réussite dans la vie je
vous l'indiquais vous m'indiquer
quelques plantes
je vais vous soignez mois pour votre
asthme mais moi je vous indiquez le
secret de la réussite c'est le travail
il y en a pas deux il y en a pas d'autre
vous pouvez lire la santé c'est le
premier bien oui mais
le si vous voulez réussir si on veut
réussir dans la vie y'a pas de miracle
il faut travailler parce qu'on a la
chance ça ne le sert comme temps et la
chance il faut toujours les alors moi
c'est sûr mais je les aime beaucoup
puisque je fais je fais partie de votre
journal je vous ai fait mon goût je
donne la permission que vous installiez
ici parce que moi je pense que vous êtes
un peuple comme les autres mais qu'il
faut pas vous chasser toujours
[Musique]
on
l'état dit
[Musique]
la mort
magharebia
wang et vanilla
[Musique]
oh
il
[Musique]
alors
oui
[Musique]
on
et de la tente à côté au bord de la
rivière et avait beaucoup du monde tu
vois dépassements et une petite
grammaire qui s'est fait tout petit
très vieille et la demande à plus
urgents de la faire passer la rivière
personne n'a voulu la faire passer la
rivière il s'occupait pas de cette
pauvre vieille parce qu'ils lui disais
qu est ce qui nous intéresse pas séduire
et qu est-ce qui la combattent fait
passer la lumière parce qu'un effet la
rivière unités pas grande c'était un
tout qui tôt ce matin que vraiment une
pitite grammaire aurait pu le traverser
60 à 100 mais je vais te l'expliquer le
frère de mon grand père
elle a été la voir il l'a pris sur sedo
et la traversée la régulière mais cette
petite grammaire c'était pas une petite
g les requins qu'il est passé l'autre
côté quand il est arrivé de la rivière
c'était une femme qui pouvait marcher et
qui était même très belle et l'a dit
quand il est passé au dessus de la
rivière et lui a dit que vous soyez pas
renié de la colère a voulu le sig un
boulet tzigane
c'est vrai vous avez aucune piqûre je
vais te le dire en main et si tu veux
vous avez pas aucune piqûre contre le
choléra jamais end s'ils gagnent a été
frappé de la choléra comme vous êtes
parent mais aussi du tonnerre
jamais personne et cigale a été touché
par le tonnerre par la foudre ok vous
êtes épargné décès de chasse à un argent
qu un moment un peu moins risqués dilolo
tout recadre apprend ne laisse pas peur
de ça quand tu as une vieille femme tu
dois lui donner la main et que le
seigneur il te donne assez de force pour
pouvoir que tu donnes mais le seigneur a
créé le monde a demandé à chacun de nous
de nous donner quelque chose
les gages et ils sont faits pour durer
la terre pour bâtir offert tous et nous
les roms quand on dit allez me donner
quelque chose d'aussi le seigneur et
voulait nous donner quelque chose pour
choisir certains ont choisi la terre
certaines ont choisi les fruits et nous
on maman canal et nous les aurons notre
tribu des roms après les gages il
n'était toujours pas ce qu'on avait une
fille qui boite et et on ne pouvait pas
arriver assez vite attends tu vois et la
fille il a vu serait pas te dire le nom
mais je vais te dire en remanient ce cas
même le nom de ce free l'épaule en elle
et à étudier le programme di carrara pas
tremblé une sauvage du cerf rouge je
fais des bonnes confitures les frères
est alors celle là qui s'est arrêté à
marie compagnie à les roms note rétribue
les roms il s'est arrêté pour attendre
la fille contenait arrivée nous autres
que le seigneur et voulait me critiquent
ce poster il y avait plus rien la brune
donc on est restés pour cueillir et ils
sont restés pour ça mais pour ça mais
[Musique]